[Musica]
quante volte ti sei sentito dire tu devi
credere nei tuoi sogni e quante volte li
ha seguiti davvero
quante volte fatto concretamente
qualcosa per realizzare i tuoi sogni nel
cassetto
come dice una delle mie canzoni
preferite i sogni dentro cassetti
marciscono
eppure la maggior parte della gente
preferisce lasciarli lì dimenticati
c'era una volta una bambina che passava
a tutti i pomeriggi nella sua cameretta
tutta rosa a creare collezioni di abiti
finendo ogni mese e decine e decine di
album quella bambina sognava di
diventare una stilista
crescendo la sua passione per la moda
per questo mondo che le sembrava così
affascinante rimasta dentro di lei anche
se aveva capito che il disegno non era
proprio il suo più grande talento
e quella bambina diventata ormai un
adolescente e venite a nata dalla sua
quotidianità
un'idea che avrebbe potuto cambiare in
parte del mondo dell'imprenditoria
italiana forse anche quello della moda
ma soprattutto la sua vita la bambina di
cui ti ho parlato sono io mi chiama
rihanna o 17 anni ea 15 ha fondato la
mia start up che ha prodotto un
applicazione nata per risolvere il
dilemma che cosa dovrà indossare per
sentirmi al meglio grazie all'innovativa
intelligenza artificiale riesce a
consigliare la fit perfetto per ogni
occasione in base ai gusti e alle
emozioni dell'utente
ho dato così il via la mia azienda
supportato ovviamente da un team
fantastico cominciato a fare col pc con
investitori lavorare su business plan e
nel frattempo coinciliare tutto questo
con la scuola e gli amici e tutte le
altre passioni
sia dieci anni mi avessero detto che
prima di finire il liceo avrei avuto una
mia azienda fatto interviste e mi
sarebbe stata data l'opportunità di
parlare su un palco the jicks avrei riso
ma poi ci avrei creduto
perché perché il credere nei miei sogni
è sempre stato più forte di qualsiasi
altra cosa
perché c'era qualcosa un fuoco dentro di
me che mi diceva che se io avessi
creduto ci sarei riuscita
e non c'è niente di più bello ma anche
di più faticoso di lavorare per un
progetto in cui si crede non c'è niente
di più soddisfacente di vedere i primi
risultati dopo tutti gli ostacoli
superati
lavorare nel mondo delle startup in un
paese ancora troppo poco propensa
l'innovazione è complicato e lo è ancora
di più se sei una ragazza di 17 anni
troppo spesso sentito dire che i giovani
non hanno voglia di fare niente quando
in realtà credo manchino solo gli
stimoli giusti dall'ambiente che ci
circonda
per questo in ogni colle con gli
imprenditori più esperti grandi di me ho
sempre voluto e soprattutto dovuto
dimostrare tanto rispetto ma soprattutto
dimostrato di essere in grado di fare
quello di cui parlavo di meritarmi quel
posto
spesso lo capivo dai loro sguardi ma le
loro parole che non credevano veramente
in me che pensavano ma che sta facendo
questa qui ha solo 16 anni che vuole
fare e del fastidioso quando capita
perché ti mette in discussione pensiero
e se non fossi in grado
ma poi mi sono sempre ricordata da dove
ero partita e dove voleva arrivare e non
mi sono mai fermata
ho cercato ancora con più determinazione
di spiegare il mio messaggio di far
capire quello che volevo fare dando la
risposta prima che mi facessero la
domanda
quindi qualsiasi strada tu voglia
intraprendere non ti fermare mai al
primo no non ti fermare mai la prima
persona che dice di non credere in te
accoglie i suoi commenti analizza lì
capisci qualcosa puoi migliorare o
cambiare ma poi va dritto per la tua
strada e trova le persone giuste che ti
possono accompagnare in questo percorso
e sarà un percorso meraviglioso
se mi fossi fermato al primo no
probabilmente sarà ancora ferma novembre
2019 quando dopo aver lavorato settimane
e settimane per la candidatura un
progetto che avrebbe potuto aiutare la
mia start up attraverso dei fondi dei
corsi con di mentre del networking mi
dissero che non ero quello che stavano
cercando
ci rimasi male certo però capì che non
poteva essere quel nome marmi che quello
forse era solo l'inizio e quindi ho
ricominciato a lavorare con più
determinazione grinta di prima
non ti fermare il meyer primo no ai una
strada bellissima davanti a te e sta
solo a te continuarla
lo sai qual è la cosa più bella che
accade quando cominci per cominci a
lavorare per seguire un tuo sogno per
raggiungerlo
che poi vedi vedi la vita in modo
diverso
non vive in funzione del weekend non
vivi aspettando un giorno qualcosa di
speciale ma capisci che ogni momento
ogni giornata negativa o monotona ha la
sua importanza perché fa parte del tuo
percorso che ti sta portando a
quell'obiettivo
quest'anno ho avuto l'opportunità di
realizzare un altro mio grandissimo
sogno studiare all'estero per tre mesi
mi sono trasferita in canada ho studiato
li ho creato una nuova vita da zero ho
conosciuto delle persone fantastiche
incontrato nuove culture ma soprattutto
ho conosciuto il nuovo a me ed è stata
un'esperienza meravigliosa non perché
frequentarsi tutti i giorni quei party
bellissimi che vediamo nei film ma
perché avevo la consapevolezza che
nonostante tutte le difficoltà che anche
che incontravo che la stavo facendo
stavo realizzando il mio sogno nel
cassetto
ora ti voglio fare una domanda
qual è il tuo di sogno nel cassetto
se chiudi gli occhi lascia andare ogni
ansia ogni paura
dovete immagini e il tuo futuro
dove vuoi arrivare
quando è fatto questo piccolo gioco apri
gli occhi
prendi un foglio e scrive il tuo sogno
non importa quanto lontano impossibili
di sembri ora
scrivilo e osservano
e comincia a pensare cosa posso fare
concretamente per realizzarlo quali sono
quei piccoli ma fondamentali passi che
devo iniziare a compiere per
raggiungerlo
e creati un piano d'azione
certo a dirla così sembra facile magari
avrai degli impedimenti iniziali oppure
lasciarla vita fatta finora di spaventa
anche io all'inizio ho paura di non
riuscire a gestire lavoro scuola amici e
tutti gli impegni che un adolescente può
avere però poi con costanza e anche
sacrificio ce l'ho fatta
certo dovrà fare delle rinunce magari
qualche festa qualche uscita ma poi se
credi in quello che stai facendo non ti
peserà niente
e ovviamente ci saranno dei momenti cui
penserai ma chi me l'ha fatto fare ma
cosa sto facendo
momenti in cui penserai di dover mollare
in cui piangerà in cui non vedrai una
luce in fondo al tunnel
però poi pensando a dove può arrivare il
suo obiettivo ce la farai perché il
carburante che ti porterà l'obiettivo
finale lo vendo troverai sempre pensando
a dove ho iniziato e dove sta andando
la vita è una e ci offre ogni giorno un
infinità di opportunità che sta solo a
noi cogliere la nostra vita il nostro
futuro sono solo nelle nostre mani
inizia a lavorare per fare a rendere
vero quel tuo sogno per rendere il
bambino che eri fiero di te
la strada che da intraprendere forse
sarà in salita anche a ri dall'inizio
ma poi alla prima vetta che raggiungerà
i di rendere conto di quanto è bello il
percorso che ha iniziato e non ti
fermerai più
quindi una volta che sarei tornato a
casa vai aprire quel cassetto marito lo
sei anche dimenticato tira fuori il tuo
sogno per non farlo marcire e comincia a
intraprendere quella strada
forse
all'inizi sentire anche un po
scoraggiato e pensare a quell'obiettivo
così grande su quei fantasticato per
anni di fa paura
ma quindi tu concentrati su dove sei ora
su i piccoli passi che devi iniziare a
compiere d'altronde le montagne non si
scalano guardando la cima
il percorso che stai per iniziare sarà
ancora più bello se lo farei
accompagnato da persone che credono in
quello che stai facendo tanto quanto
io sono stata molto fortunata perché da
quando sono piccolo i miei genitori mi
hanno sempre sostenuta sempre mutilata
in meno sempre tu sei un sogno provaci
credici in particolare mio padre che in
questo percorso imprenditoriale è stato
il primo a credere in me
mi ricordo ancora il mercoledì piovoso
di novembre in cui gli presentare la mia
idea
lui mi guarda negli occhi mi disse che
la trova interessante che potevo
provarci ma mi fece subito capire che
non sarebbe stato un gioco
infatti vi assicuro che non lo è stato
ho perso il conto delle notti passate in
bianco a correggere presentazione
studiare i business plan scrivere
rispondere e mail a volte anche a
litigare per delle idee diverse ma senza
tutti quei momenti difficili non avrei
apprezzato poi tutti i risultati
raggiunti dopo
e quindi forse sono su questo palco
oltre del meeting del merito c'è anche
il suo
quindi comincia a lavorare
inizia a rendere in realtà quel sogno
circondati dalle persone giuste e non ti
fermare mai credi sempre in te stesso
perché ce la puoi fare
ho iniziato questo discorso con una
citazione e voglio concludere con
un'altra che da quando sono piccola mi
dice il mio papà e che mi motiva ad
andare avanti a superare tutti gli
ostacoli momenti no quei momenti che
sembrano la fine del mondo
le strade più impervie sono quelle che
portano alle vette più belle
[Applauso]
[Musica]